Chicago a city known for some truly
great museums like the world famous Art
Institute of Chicago but a lesser-known
institution has its own special purpose
to Showcase The Works of American
Veterans as Charlie Demar reports it's a
place both for art to be seen and
stories to be heard
in Chicago there's a home for the Art of
War the national veterans Art Museum
offers space for those who served to
share their stories talent and Trauma
well that mission right there
was what we do
Search and Destroy artists like Dr
Charles Smith 82 now 25 when he got
drafted and the Marines sent him to
Vietnam art has helped him heal ever
since and I felt when I got home that it
was necessary
to make sure that that
Legacy of that war was not forgotten
especially the most important part of it
that blacks and whites fought together
we died together Smith's combat tour may
have been more than a half century ago
but he says vets of all ages understand
the weight of War you got to get to the
place
not a psychiatrist not a counselor
but somebody that had beared the burden
that you burn
and that way they can counsel you out of
it what stands out about these pieces
yeah I think the the experience of of
women in the military Giselle Futrell
enlisted in the Marines right out of
high school and was in Afghanistan by
the time she was 21. now she's the
Museum's executive director you walk in
here you see images of War of soldiers
experiences what to you what is this
space it's a place to inspire dialogue
it's a place where we can start to talk
about the things that are uncomfortable
you know human beings aren't uh aren't
designed to to go to those uncomfortable
places but sometimes we have to if we
want to make progress the best thing
that the public can do for our veterans
is to listen so this is a place of
listening
to a truth that can not only inform but
help heal for CBS Saturday morning
Charlie Demar Chicago